Good morning. Hi. Jinks, buy me a Coke. Do you drink Coke? Do you even know what a Coke is? No, I don't. And what is that? Hang on a second.
Jinks, buy me a Coke? You never heard Jinks, buy me a Coke? When you say the same thing, you go, Jinks, buy me a Coke. I've never heard buy me a Coke. Is that a Chicago thing maybe? I don't know. I think it's a universal American thing.
No, I've been living in America for quite some time, and I've worked for Universal. Oh, that's right. And neither of those instances did I hear that phrase. Welcome to a new smart list. Smart. Hey, Sean. Sean, you got up a little early today and did your hair, huh?
Well, this is left over from last night. But I got it. Did you sleep in a bonnet? No. You know my daughters? My daughter's both sleep in bonnets now, so their hair wakes up nice and fresh. Really? Yeah.
Yeah, I don't think. It's like silky satin bonnets. Look at yours. Like a night shirt and a bonnet when they walk around with a candle. The candle. The candle. Like Scrooge. Yeah.
Oh. Oh, Jesus. Oh, he is ill. Yeah, I'm fucking sick still. Yeah. How about I got two colds in two weeks? I know. I can't believe back.
I've got Theraflu going right now. I did that same thing, J.B., we were talking about yesterday. I had three colds since October, and they just went back to back to back. It's like, insane. Yeah. Why am I such a bitch when I'm sick? Are you on the mend? Yeah, but I still coughing and I'm grouchy and draggy and spoky.
Can Sean bring you something? Yes, I did offer... No, he... I get it. I know who's a caretaker here. Oh, how dare you? He did offer twice yesterday. I know.
Such an angel. Well, I mean, do you really want me to? Well, no, I haven't asked you for anything yet, but I'm good. I'm all right. If you want something, Nick is happy to bring something over for sure. My assistant. Will, where are you? Are you in L.A.?
I'm home. I'm in L.A. Yeah, it's so nice. Wait, so you're closer to me than Sean is, so you can bring me something. I would love to... I would love to. And if I'm just looking at my calendar now, I would love to.
You're looking for sleeves for your shirt? Today? Yeah. I know. Says me, listen, at least I'm wearing just because it's like gym wear. You know what I mean?
I'm not like pulling a throw. Are you guys bitches when you're sick? Yes. Yeah, I'm the worst. All dudes are. All dudes are. I'm the worst.
I don't know. I think some guys can just kind of push through it. No. Me, I like cancel everything. I'm surprised I didn't get. Well, I know why I didn't cancel this.
Yeah. I know I didn't cancel this. This has been canceled before. I know you, you, I know I ran into somebody on the weekend, J.B. And, sorry, I'm hearing less gain from Rob for me. Okay, got you. Loud and clear, Rob. Thank you.
Jesus. Wait, did he give you a side text to lower your gain? Yeah, he did. He's like, so rude. Too much of you. And you know what I mean? Anyway, somebody I ran into this weekend said you were supposed to do something and that you had to cancel because you were sick.
That probably would have been me. Yeah, I was supposed to go to a party with Shawnee. Yeah. And what else? Oh, I was supposed to do some frickin' press thingy, and I couldn't. It was a press thing. And Amanda and Frannie were in New York having fun. And me and Maple, Maple, she's the fucking dirty carrier that gave me this cold.
I love when people get into, I love when people start to try to do, like, who they got the cold from. And it's their fault. just get it from, you know what I mean? I know, but it's, it's her. I had just gotten over COVID. I was weak. Remind us how old maple is again? I was supposed to be babysitting and she's, you know what?
I had to test her temperature by, do you guys do this? You put your lips on the forehead. You put your lips on the forehead of someone to find out if they're running a fever or not because your lips will tell you. You can't put your hand against it because your hand is hot or cold, but whatever. You mean your lips. Yeah, if you rest your lips. Before thermometers, for sure, that's what we did.
But for sure. And I think I got it by doing that, putting lips against her sweaty. No, you can't get it from that. How do you get it? You probably, she sneezed on her hand or something. She touched the surface and you touched the surface right after. You just didn't know. Who knows? You both got it from somewhere else.
I mean, what is she going to start to do? What are you going to sue the person you got? No, I know. I know. I know. Remember that during COVID? Everyone was like, who do you think they got it from? I know.
Yeah, yeah. Who do you think? I know. Yeah. Anyway. I like it's their fault. Anyway. Anyway, look, Jay, you have 50 minutes
before you can go back to sleep. All right. Hey, I think maybe we should move tomorrow's thing to the Zoom. I don't know if I can make it to that lunch. Oh, what do you think about that? What do you think? Oh, yeah.
What do you think? Yeah, we can do that. Yeah, all right. I love it. I'd love to not see you tomorrow, to be honest, if you are still ill. Yeah, see, no one wants to get sick. No.
All right, here we go. I'm going to fucking pull up my bootstraps for this one, because this is, listen. Can I just say this for your, Can I just say for your guest, again, I want to reiterate, because you are such a baby. And the fact, no, I'm going to say a baby. And the fact that you did do this is a real sign of respect to the guest,
because knowing you and knowing how selfish you are, this is remarkable that you were able to sort of. This is a big deal for me. It's a big deal. I know this person, you must. You must. A tiny bit, but I want to know her more. Our guest today, this is the second youngest actress ever to win an Oscar.
and the youngest person ever to be nominated three times. She knows how to act, but it's not because she went to some fancy drama school. She's self-taught. She also knows about world issues and is a fierce advocate for the less fortunate, but not because she went to some fancy live arts college. She's self-educated. She's glamorous, but she's not a diva. She's a major movie star, but she keeps it real, yo.
And she has enormous wealth, but she still lives in her first car with her husband and two toddlers. Let's find out how she does it all, guys. Please welcome Ms. Jennifer Schrader Lawrence Maroni. I don't live in my car. You too live in your car. Living in your car. Are you referring to this TikTok? I've seen it.
Oh, no. Really? Oh, there's a TikTok that... Where you're living in your car? That my friend's nanny was like... It's like, Jennifer Lawrence, no matter how much wealth she has. She's never moved out of her first house. And she still drives her like the same car, but the car is like an old Buick.
Will's already trying to pull it up. I don't have TikTok. I'm not. I was putting my thing on Do Not Service. Hi, guys. Hi. I listened to this podcast. I'm really excited to be honest.
Do you really? So, dude, she was supposed to be, she was my guest for the bowl. Yes. Yes. I know. I found out. How excited were you, Jennifer? To get the canceled.
When it got canceled. Was that just like the greatest call ever? For, I mean, for a person like me who likes to sit at home all day, when the rain came in. Yeah. You know, it felt like a blessing. Sure. Yeah. But I don't know if I go that.
But I have, yeah, it seems like God was shining down. Yeah. Just the smartless cast and me. It would have been nice to be out there. How fun to be out there at the bowl. Would you guys, you guys wouldn't get stage, well, you guys do this in front of audiences a lot. So you're used to. I would have been nervous.
I would have been nervous. Yeah. That's a big deal. The bowl. Is that a part of like you being like a little bitch? I am a little bitch. Of what you were saying earlier. Sorry, you brought it up, not me.
Yeah. I would have faked it though. But he found the time to comb his hair today, which is nice. I didn't expect one of you to be in a tank top. I know, I'm sorry, it's not a tank. It's not a tank. It's a sleeveless t-shirt like Justin Thoreau. Is it from Thoreau's target line?
He's got a new line at Target, doesn't he? He wishes, he should have a line at Target. Obviously, I thought you guys meant Thoreau. Oh, no. Is that from the Rowe? That would be a good way for him to market. The Rowe. Yeah.
No, I was at the gym. Pardon my appearance. Jennifer, so nice to meet you. do we find you today? Jesus. I am in my bedroom in New York. I'm in my car. My first car.
If you had to live in a car, what kind of car do you think it would be? Oh, good course. Like a camper van. Yeah. How about, Willie, I haven't talked to you about this. The new VW electric bus
that you drive in your new movie? It's rad. Yeah. I know. It's really cool. But that car was, like, I fantasize it. I want that car.
Is it great? Yeah. I mean, it's, yes. Listen to how careful he has to be with his GMC contract. And I'm thinking about my Hyundai thing right now and thinking, we've got to cut this. But I think that things pretty...
I'm a Volvo gal myself. Are you? Wait, do you do the Volvo voice? X-C-90. What? No, you're not... You don't do the voice. Oh, no, I just drive a Volvo.
You drive. Oh, you do. An Audi, I'm an Audi. No one's asking. My husband's an Audi guy. Is he? Yeah. Well, this is what it's like to be one of the guys.
This is one of the cars. Wait. Yeah, but I would say, to answer your question, My question would be a GMC-UConn-X-L-Denali funnel. Oh, Jesus. Wait, where are my questions? Here I come.
Blue, I have a blue one. Sorry. All right. Is it Jen or is it Jennifer? Jen. Jennifer, if you're, like, trying to get my attention. Jennifer, if I'm scolding you. Jennifer.
What about how cool that middle name Schrader is? I like that. Yeah, I didn't care about it growing up, but... You didn't like it? Yeah, no. That's cool. Is that a family name? Can you imagine if it wasn't a family name?
name. It's my grandma's maiden name. That's a great first name. Because Jason hasn't bothered to get to this, where are you from? I don't know enough about it. I don't know enough about you. I want to know. I want to know.
Guess. Guess? Guess. Guess? Yeah. Guess. I feel like this is kind of well known. I wonder if there's a state that will offend me.
Can I tell you, there might be. Can I tell you something? It's because the first time I think that I saw you in something was, is it is, maybe I'm going to tell you. Winterbone. I think of you of being from like Missouri. Appalachia. Or Appalachia or whatever it is.
That's in my mind. That's how great you are in that. Oh, thank you. So I'm going to say you are from... Take your time well. Can I just say West Virginia? You can. Again, adjacent.
Kentucky, all right? Kentucky. Oh, okay. All right? How about that? Yeah. Yeah. Now, that's my first question.
You grew up in Kentucky with two older brothers, Jen. And you have said that you were always a tough kid. How do you think that environment shape the kind of roles you were grabbing? See, this is not. What I need to do, I got to read the questions first, and I'm going to make them my own. Are we still rolling? This is such a loose operation.
Hey, you're not wearing a shirt. So you got two brothers. You got it. All right. So, but now, do you think, here's the way I would phrase a question. All the roles that you play, they do, you shut up.
They have a, they have a, they have a, they have a sass to them. And do you think that the sass is in the part, or do you bring the sass to it? Ah. Thank you. Oh, goodness. I mean, most of the time, yeah, it's in the part. I recently saw Merrill Streep say a quote that was, you know,
she seems like she knows what she. she's doing. She was like, it's about like finding the similarities between the two of us and like bridging a gap. And I was like, okay, so that'll be my thing too now. Right. But I feel like that. I try to do that mostly because I like you, I'm completely untrained and it's all just sort of like for me, I don't want to make this about me, but we're going to for a second, I kind of try to find what is the part of me that's closest to the part. And it seems like, because I never catch you acting, that it seems like you're staying
inside your goalposts, your, the limits of what different parts of Jen is. You have no limits in my view, sorry. Yeah. You know? Would that be fair that maybe you were doing what Merrill was talking about and she just kind of put words to it?
Yeah, I think that's fair. Where's everybody from? Can we do a roll call? Yeah. Sean? I'm from Chicago, Illinois. I love Chicago. Isn't Chicago? Isn't Chicago great? Yeah, the vibe is cool. This is a slippery slope, Jen. What he loves to talk about Chicago?
Oh, my God. There we go. It's pretty fantastic. People from Chicago, they really love it. In the suburbs, like right outside of Chicago. No way. By the way. This is my high school.
I'm wearing the T-shirt. Are you serious? What are the odds? And then she mentioned it and then you're wearing it. Yeah. Jen, why do you love Chicago so much? You have you done time there? Done time.
It's about 16 months up in Chicago. I had like cousins that lived there, so then I would go and visit as a kid. Have you ever worked there? No, I've never worked there. Yeah, it's pretty cool. Your cousins in one of those suburbs, like in planes, trains and automobiles,
when he comes home to that house for Thanksgiving, that to me, that's the idyllic suburban. You know that's like the only Thanksgiving movie? I put it on yesterday for my 13-year-old as a Christmas movie, and she saw in the little synopsis right before I click play. She goes, wait a second, this is Thanksgiving. I'm like, it doesn't matter. It's a great holiday movie.
She goes, no, I'm out. Sounds like you're a kid. Yeah, but Jen, you know, it was wild. I was a teenager growing up in Chicago when John Hughes wrote and filmed all of them surrounding me, like in all the neighborhoods around. And I was in high school when they would come out, pretty in pink, you know, home alone or whatever.
Per's Bueller. but Ferris Bueller, like all those so was like, wow, and it was so enamored. We're talking about your affinity for Ducky and how much you identified with Ducky. I would call Ducky all the time. No way. Shocker. But anyway, but did you, so that was the thing that influenced me was being a, Hollywood coming to Chicago. And I was like, wow, it was so close to me.
What was that for you in Louisville? Well, I just want to, it's interesting when your age lines up with the movies that are coming out. I had that with Harry Potter. I was like 11 when the books came out and like 12. What was Hollywood like in Kentucky? No, but men like what was the influence for you? What was the outside influence to go,
wow, I want to do that. Oh, well, I don't, I mean, really nothing. It never occurred to me that that would be a thing. Or possible, you know, I wanted to be a mom. I wanted to be an interior designer, which I'm not good at that. I just, that was a job option.
But anyway. And then I went to, New York with my mom on like a long weekend from school and we were watching street dancing in Union Square and I got like discovered. Oh really? Really? Were you a break dancer? Is that what you mean like breakdancing?
I was waiting to get on the cardboard. Yeah. I did that too. That's crazy. No, I did not. No, she's kidding. Oh, I did it. That's cool.
Wait, street dancing. So what you were just watching and somebody saw you? Yeah, I didn't. We don't get a lot of that in Kentucky. So my mom and I were just like, what's this? And then somebody, what?
How were you discovered? Yeah, wait, well, what happened? This guy, like, came over and was like, I worked for a modeling agency, can I take your picture? And my mom and I were like, you know, had no survival instincts. We're like, sure, do you want to go to a hotel? Wait, wait. Do you want to take pictures of me?
That seems like you want to take pictures. Furt, on, off, what do you think? Top's on? Wait, wait, wait, so they go, so this person comes up, I want to know this, so this person comes up and goes, hey we're from a modeling agency we want you to we want to sign you we want to do a picture whatever that that is that's sort of creepy and then what's the what's the progression from there how does that all how do you start making movies um i signed with an agency that allowed me to like act which was like
commercials and stuff out of louisville or this is still no i so we had to go back to louisville but now that i knew that this was an opportunity i was just like and um i i had to I had actually made money. I'd saved money from babysitting, but also I trained horses. And so I had, like, you know, a couple grand. And I was like, I'm going. And I was 14.
Wow. And originally my brother came with me, who was like 18. And we were just like, we are going to die. Wait, just the two of you. Just the two of us. No. To New York. Yeah.
Our first meal was at Applebee's in Times Square. No way. Because Sabarro was closed. Yeah. I think mine was at the M&M store or whatever. But wait, what about... Last meal. She said first meal. Okay.
You were 14 and how old was your brother at the time? 18. Wow. And your mom and dad were just like, great, go have a good time. Yeah. I mean, they were supportive. I know that it's weird as parents to hear it back. I mean, but at the time it was like...
I think... I don't know. I think they could tell that this was just like kind of happening. And so they tried to like make it as safe as possible. Right. Right. So they gave, so they sent me with my brother. So you just dropped out of school? Yeah, I dropped out of school. I was supposed to, I was only going to do it for the summer and then come back for school. But at the end of summer, I had booked a sitcom that shot in L.A. This is the Billing Ball Show?
And then I was supposed to get like, you know, you're supposed to like graduate, like get homeschooled for your credits or whatever. but we just kind of left it. Left it. Yeah. Oh, wow. Leave it. And who drove you to L.A.? Was it the photographer?
In a van. In a van. My dad drove us in the Black Era from Kentucky to L.A. Wow. Wow. Why didn't we fly? We needed a car in L.A.
We needed a car in L.A. Okay. And we did a perfect swap. We swapped our apartment in New York for somebody else's house in L.A. And it was just a Craigslist situation. Oh, wow. They sub-let your apartment, you mean?
Yeah, and then we take their house. It's just a bunch of gypsies. Just running around the country, chasing an artistic dream. I love it. I know. It's like rehearsal season two and it's like, this guy's going to fly you on a camera. And he's like, how many people said no?
And he's like, no button. And he's like, actors, dude. Yeah. Such intense dreamers. I saw that. That was good. and we will be right back. And now, back to the show.
So you're out to L.A., you're still fortunate. So this is months after this Union Square moment. Months later, you book a sitcom, like pretty early on. Do we know the sitcom, or was there just a pilot? Bill Engval. It was called the Bill Engval show. It didn't do very well. I mean, it came out on TBS, and I got a steady paycheck for a while.
And on the, I mean, for like two. years, two and a half years, and then I booked Winter's Bone on the hiatus of that show, and then the show got canceled, which was perfect timing. Wow. So were, this first... And just like the rain canceling our show. It was just like... It's just like the rain. It's a blessing.
It's looking down. But this first exposure to acting and stuff, it felt like an early fit. This was something that you, it was comfortable. This is something I want to do the rest of my life. It was so comfortable that I found ways I thought it had to be harder. So I remember
or like I would like read like an audition, like I would read sides. And I'd be like, well, this is how a normal person would say it. And then so I would change that and be like, so maybe I will say it like this. Right, right, right, right. Well, that's really interesting though, because people do, they, I don't know,
I feel like some people like, that give like performances will get like nominations. And then other people that just kind of like just do naturalistic, just kind of disappear, let the story take over, don't really get as much attention as like the flash. sort of performance actor. You're so naturalistic, yet you are incredibly well,
what would you call, awarded, nominated? Recognized. Recognized, thank you. I'm sick, you guys. So that is, I love that. Do you think that maybe that's because you didn't go to acting school
and learn how to act? You know? You know, my mom took me to some guy that like the agency. Don't worry, it doesn't end like that. Okay. But my mom took me to this guy that this agency told me to me to help me
act or whatever. Right. And he told my mom, don't put her in any, you know, acting lessons. Don't do that. That guy randomly is Taylor Sheridan. Oh, wow. Weird.
Wait, wait, what? Isn't that crazy? I guess he was like an acting teacher or something back in the day. That's crazy. Wait. I feel like he was an, I think his story is that he was an act.
actor, right? And then started writing and wrote... Sicario. That was kind of around for a while. And, DeNi... Yeah, it's great. And DeNee found it. Remember he told that story? He just... He kind of found it. It was like, wait, this is the greatest script I've ever read. For Tracy, just so she knows Taylor Sheridan created Yellowstone. I feel like Tracy doesn't need any help on that one.
Yeah, yeah. Well, she may. She may. So he was also... So he was also teaching acting. That's amazing. I love that note. Don't take her to acting school. She'll learn how to act. and what a great piece of advice that was because you don't do that. You're very easy to watch, Mrs.
Wow, so Taylor Sheridan was the guy. So did you, have you guys ever talked about doing somebody? Was there any follow-up to that relationship or no? It was just that brief period and then you moved on. No, just that brief period. Wow. And you haven't run into him since. No, we met up about like another project,
but we didn't talk about it because I don't know if we even made the connection. somebody made the connection for me when I was doing a Q&A for a movie like two or three years ago so we just might not even remember that connection oh yeah I know I mean why would he I was just like a little kid right let's get him on the horn
yeah that's wild all right so all the so the acting is comfortable you're getting some good you're getting good jobs you get Winter's bone and winter's bone gets Sean would give anything to have a winter's bone.
What do you do? Yeah. Don't give anything. You give anything. Because your bear goes into hibernation during the winter, right, Shoney? Yeah, exactly. We got it right there. It's not until spring.
That little cub doesn't come back with a phone until spring. They're so proud of themselves. She's so... It's so fun. It's so fun. Now we're cooking with gas. Good bit, guys. So wait.
So, Jen. So now Winter's Bone comes out. Everybody loves Jennifer Lawrence. Yes. Looks like we've got a career ahead of us. And now it's we really don't need to do the school thing. That was already kind of decided, but now this solidified it, right? Yeah.
Well, by then, I mean, I still feel this way. I still feel overwhelmed. Like when I hear that somebody, like, graduated or something, I have envy of the, like, organization of even just, like, having the credits or, like, knowing how to, I wouldn't even know where to get started. I think I would have to start from like sixth grade or something. Whatever, I don't have to do it. I get anxiety randomly that I'll have to do it.
But you don't have any regrets about missing out on it. I did. Now I don't. But I was really lonely. I didn't have any social life as a kid. I didn't have any friends, you know, as a teenager. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, but did you ever have to go to school on set? Were you emancipated? No, that's why we did. did it, I think, because you have to pay if you're not emancipated, then they have to pay for a tutor for you if you're underage.
And so our way of making me enticing, I think, was that we said I had a GED. So we didn't need the onset tutor, so I was an inexpensive minor. So my mom had my boyfriend at the time print out like a GED or a diploma or something
on, like, Microsoft Word. And it's not like a studio was going to be like, Hey, let's check this out. So it was fake. Fake. Fake G. Yeah, it was fake. God, I love this family.
This family is incredible. Yeah, you should see it at Christmas. We really rip. All right, but now, because I don't know. My mom one time I brought like a British boyfriend home, and they had in celebration of me coming home, roasted a pig on a spit. And my boyfriend was very fancy,
and I don't think like wanted to eat it, but was being polite and was eating it. And my mom was like, when I saw that naked, pig on the spit. I couldn't help myself. I leaned right in and gave it a kiss. And wouldn't you know it? Two weeks later, I got ringworm. No way. Must meet your mom. Making a know. Oh my gosh. But I, you know, I don't have a high school diploma either and I get very, very jealous of people that are in college, that are listening to like professors, give lectures. But it's so funny because then I hear both
you, Jay and you, Jennifer, talk about that. Sorry, Jen. And, and it's like that we all, okay, S-H. Yeah. Yeah, that, I know, that's my initials are, that, what was going to say? That, from your perspective, you were like, oh my God, I'm so jealous of people who went to college. But as a kid who wanted to act when I was really young, I was like envious of you guys. I was like, oh, that seems. But are you envious now?
Yeah, not really. Well, I like my experience quite a lot, yeah. You did. I mean, you're a hilltopper for life, obviously. That's right. That's what the T-shirt says of his school. J.B., I didn't realize that we had so much in common like this. I mean, but what was your way to self-educate?
Mine was watching Charlie Rosen and trying to read newspapers. Yeah, I watched a lot of like the History Channel and Animal Planet. I would go to the library, I didn't have like a library card. My family, we just weren't like organized. We didn't like pay for things. So I would go, but then I would just read about like. Did you sneak in?
Magic. The library. Read about magic? I'm going to get a degree in magic. Yeah. I mean, left to my own devices. I mean, have you continued on the legacy of chaos in your own family moving forward? Do you keep a sort of a healthy dose of chaos?
That's such a good question. I married somebody who is the opposite of me. He is so organized. He's an anchor. He's an anchor. Everything's ordered. Everything is ordered. Like on the sink.
Like I have to, you know, like, keep the closet doors closed. And I have, like, my little jobs that I work really hard to do. What's the thing you just can't fucking do, God damn it? And he gets after you all the time. Jen, what's the matter with you? Why can't you blank? Right. Oh, I know, I know, I know, the schedule.
So what, our kids, I mean, I'm, I get it now. I get it, but like they're on a very strict schedule, you know? It's like breakfast 7.30, like, I don't know. He does most of that. Well, he just keeps. He's good at keeping the time. He's good at keeping it, but we've learned to keep our marriage alive. I have a 15-minute wiggle room.
Right. Because I just, you know. You can't be held. to the precise times, otherwise the marriage is going to suffer. Yeah, because I can't. I will, yeah, I'm ADD. And I think I should go to like occupational therapy for that. But I don't know.
Is anybody here ADD? I think I am or I'm obsessive, consult compulsive a little bit. Like, or at least about being on time. Like I'm usually on time, but I'm never early. Because I feel like if I get someplace early, I'm wasting that amount of time because nothing's going to happen until it's supposed to happen. Oh, I don't know. I have to be on time or I get anxious.
But what I do is I picture what is happening, like what the day is, where it's going to be, where everything's happening. None of that is like confirmed or real. But my imagination about it is so strong. Like yesterday, we were going to the circus. We were going to go to the circus at 11. I didn't buy tickets.
And then the next thing I knew, I looked at my phone and I was like building a snowman with my son in the backyard and it was 1230. And the circus was at 11. Like stuff like that. Like it's pretty toxic. Because you didn't see on the schedule or because what? I do follow the schedule.
Like I am like capable of doing that. But when I mess up, those are the mess ups. Yeah, yeah, yeah. How about like the iPhone was such? I used to be just in a sea of post-its before the iPhone. Like I couldn't remember anything. I was always like missing appointments. But now the iPhone with the little alarm situation,
little calendar. It doesn't work for me. Watch this. I tried it last night. Uh-oh. Siri, tell me I'm beautiful in one hour. I don't see I'm beautiful in your contacts. It just never does it.
See? Yeah, I get it. And then it'll just, like, call my trainer. Because it wants to help you get beautiful. Listen. Yeah, it's very instinctual. What about a nice assistant? Let's get you a nice assistant or two.
Oh, I have a nice assistant. of the best. I love my assistance. But it's really hard what I put them through. I know, it's not that bad. I mean, my God, I'm a mother. My kids get to school on time. Yeah, yeah.
Now, okay, so everything's cruising along, and it's feeling kind of normal. Winter's bone happens. And that's just like... Winter's bone happens. No, it wasn't exactly like that. I got nominated, but, you know, it was like...
At 20. It was an indie, and I still kind of felt like I was going to just be like an indie actress because I had starred in a couple other things that were like small and I had gotten like little awards for them like two other jobs. But you still have kind of an indie
indie vibe like in the best way. I mean that as a compliment. Yeah, yeah, you do. I think it as a compliment. Thank you. You do. And so I was like, yeah, this is going to be, this is, I'm right on track.
I'm going to be like the indie lady. And then I auditioned for the Hunger Games. And then when I booked the Hunger Games, It was the same kind of season as like award season for, no way. That was silver linings. So I got famous just from booking Hunger Games. Oh, because the people who were fans of the book were like, oh, she's going to be. Yeah.
Yeah, because I used to do the Santa Monica Stairs. And I remember being like, I don't think I can do the Santa Monica Stairs anymore. I'm too famous. So then were you reluctant? You were reluctant to take that part? because you thought it was going to be too... Yeah. I thought it was going...
Yeah, Twilight had come out and it was like, holy fucking shit. Like, there were like helicopter pictures of them, like just trying to live in a guest house. And it just didn't seem like a nice life. And I had a good situation. Like, I had enough money for what I... You know, and I could do what I want.
Like, there was just... I didn't know if it was going to be worth it. You know, exciting, but maybe not ultimately worth it. And I did... I was always focused on, like, my future being a mom. And so I was like, I picture myself being a soccer mom, a minivan. And like, you know, and what if I'm, what if I can't do that? Because there's like, you know, I'm like Kim Kardashian or something.
But I thought about it. And then I said yes, and I don't regret it. But wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, before you said yes, well, take us through the sort of the deliberation process. Did you, did you reach out? Was it like agents, parents, friends, or all the above that helped you come to that decision? or was it just you running up the Santa Monica stairs and figuring it out? It was just me, you know, running up the Santa Monica stairs because there's not really anybody that can help you.
Like, you know, mostly everybody's like, are you insane? You have to say yes to that. You're going to regret that for the rest of your life. And then taking time to, like, think about, I knew that I'd be connected to that character forever, which isn't good or bad. It was just something to think about. And I ultimately, I'm so happy about that.
I love that. I know, isn't the new one about to come out? Like all these years later? Yeah. Yeah. Isn't it funny too? Like you, as an actor, you like work towards, you know, becoming successful. And then you have exactly what you're talking about, the struggle of, well, I know this is going to be successful. You know, do I associate myself with that?
But that's the thing where we want. We want to be successful. Anybody wants to be successful in any job they do. I know. But our job is very closely connected with our lives. Right. I mean, I guess everybody says. Yeah. So you say yes to the thingy at the Hunger Games, and then you get the nomination.
And then my saying yes happened. Like that was announced in the same season as award season for Silver Linings Playbook. Oh, wow. Which I was like winning all of those awards leading up to that you win, like before you win the Big Daddy. And so I became the most famous person in the world. And I was like so. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, it was fast.
And tell me, an honest ratio between excitement and fear and panic. Oh, God, I don't know, because they blend. Right. It must have been exciting for a second. It was very exciting. It was so exciting. But I was also, like, working really, like, the whole time. I didn't have, like, during that era, I didn't have, like, more than.
two weeks off in like five years. So when I was like going to the awards things, when I won, I was shooting, catching fire. And I was like, I mean, even, yeah, I was like flying in and out to go to a party and then landing at four in the morning and then going to set for the Hunger Games at 7 in the morning. So just I don't think I ever got,
like by the time I finished the Hunger Games, they like came back to like the condo that I lived in when I was like a teenager because I just didn't. live anywhere. Right. And it was probably a great distraction to, like the craziness was a distraction to not absorb everything. Yeah, and I like lived with my best friend. So that was nice. That definitely stopped me from getting full of myself. But when the music kind of stopped, when you came back to the condo after all that time, did you feel like, oh my, did it feel like a, such a big part of your
life had just kind of gone by? You can't go to Starbucks anymore. And like all that stuff started to really kind of. Did it feel like a time warp? Yeah. Yeah, but you know what? It was like, I am a home body and I realized that I could use this to my advantage. And that was cool. I can just be like, oh, I can't come to your party. I'm too famous. I can't leave the house. Like being pregnant, right?
You can just say, oh, yeah, no, I got to go. I got to leave early. Like being pregnant? Well, yeah, my wife. Do you do that like when your wife is pregnant? Yeah. It was like, it's a great way to get out of a party early or you have the baby at home, you know. Oh, yeah.
Now with kids, you don't have to do anything. Sean still does it with his dog, Ricky. Yeah. Sean does it all the time. He's like, we've got to get back to Ricky. And we're like, at 7 p.m. You've been gone two hours. Did you leave a bunch of food out?
No, well, I mean... Do you not have kids? I don't have... We don't have kids, no, but we have a dog. Not human kids. You have such calm dad energy. I know. You know what?
It's because I didn't have one. So, that's another podcast. But yeah, because I didn't have one. So I think... I have a fantasy of being a dad because of the way I wasn't fathered. but then we've had this conversation so many times about, you know, I've written like three jokes since you've been talking about just driving fast, about stick shift.
Go ahead, keep going. But yeah, no, but I always said neither me or Scotty, my husband is 100% wanting kids. And I was like, if he was 100% it was like, oh my God, I want him. I want him somebody. Then I'd be like, great, let's do it. But we're both like 85, you know, like so it's not fair to the kid. I do feel though that like during the nine months it takes to make a baby, it helps. That's a useful time for parents to kind of get their head around becoming parents.
So take that for what it's worth. I don't know. Whenever anybody tells me like I'm not sure. I'm like, don't do it. Yeah. Because I feel it's so weird that people are like, oh, you don't have kids. You don't have kids. And then when you have a kid, you're like, what the fuck?
Everybody should have been like, when I said, it should have been one out of a thousand people that goes, okay, I think I'm going to do it. And everybody's like, are you sure? Right, right, right, right. Like that's the way it should be. And it doesn't help, like I said this too, it doesn't help like while somebody's rocking their screaming baby,
you know, behind their back, they go, don't have kids. Yeah. You know, and like, okay, well, it's seen that enough. We're doing bits. It's just bits. We're doing bits. We'll be right back. And now back to the show.
But speaking of babies, Jen, now are you the soccer mom that you were dreaming about? Yeah. Are you tempted to like... I'm an ice hockey mom. No. Yeah. I never saw that coming in Kentucky.
I'm an ice hockey mom. Yeah. Wait, the four-year-old is playing ice hockey? Yeah. Or is a dad? Yeah. No. The four-year-old.
Yeah. Yeah. That's a cool. I mean, my husband played hockey growing up, and he's... That's so hot. when they play hockey together, like in the house. Like, it really turns me on. Is he Canadian?
No, we'll almost, Vermont. Okay, good, yeah, yeah. We love hockey. Hockey's my sport. But what about that? Has that hockey gear started smelling yet on the four-year-old? Because the hockey gear is bad. No, he told me I had to brush my teeth yesterday.
Oh, do you're a husband or your kid? He was like, you should brush your teeth, Mommy. Yeah, they'll tell you straight. I used to have to bring my hockey equipment in the side and had to take it to the basement because it smelled. so bad. The hockey bag is the worst. My mom would be like
I don't have that yet. Had to keep it in the boiler room at the house because it smelled so bad. Wait, so, but Jen, don't you just want to... What do you do about that? Baking soda? Nothing. It just is what it is, eh?
You go buy new stuff. Yeah. Are you Canadian? I'm Canadian, yeah. Oh. Boy. Yeah, that'll stop. We'll tighten everything.
It really landed. I'm tempted to just like not ever. work again and just be home with kids and like, yeah. That's, I identify as a stay-at-home mom. Yeah.
But I am obviously. When he says home and kids, he means on the golf course, but listen. I've lost my passion for that lately. I don't know what's going on. I know. Same here. You're just sick. You'll get it back. You'll say, yeah.
No, but I do, I do love I love not doing anything. Like right now we're, listener, we're in the holidays, right now, this will air later, but the two weeks around Christmas and New Year's, I just love that there's nothing to do except just stay in your PJs, make a fire, and watch movies. Yeah, I love that. Yeah, nothing's required.
I'm not used to being busy like this. I normally, like, I have a busy, like, three months while I'm filming, you know. But even in that sense, it's calm because there is nothing else to do. Right. I just go to work. I do that. I come home, I sleep, and then I do it again. Right.
And then like two weeks while you promote it is hectic. But like something like this, where I'm like doing the, I don't know. Right. So right now you're doing some campaigning and it's busy. You've got to do a bunch of stuff like this. How do you like doing stuff like this? I like doing stuff like this. This is like a fun conversation with interesting people.
Right, as opposed to doing like a. When do they get here? But like Q&A's, you know, like a Q&A that like starts at 9, like 9 p.m. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, after the screen. How do you stay awake? What time do you go to bed?
I have half an eye open at 8.30. Oh, I am in bed. Kindle is lit until like 9.15. And then I don't even have like Kendall light on normally by 915. So Kindle will put you to sleep? Yeah. The reading puts you to sleep. Yeah.
Yeah, Will's a big reader. You know, that's true. The older you get, I went to a couple parties that started at like 8 o'clock at night. I'm like, who starts a party at 8? Well, that one this weekend that I couldn't go to, started at 8. What time did you get there? I got there right at 8. Right at 8.
So you could leave at 8.30? I was planning on going to a Christmas party tomorrow, but it starts at 9. Yeah, what? That's rude. You know, all that means is that we're going to be drinking a lot. When you set your time start at 9, that means it's going to be a lot of booze. And I just, you can't be hungover with a 9-month-old. No.
No. It's just not an option. Wait, Jen, when you were imitating your mom, that was so funny, and she had, that southern, you know, drawl or twang or whatever. Did you have that and got rid of it or did you never have it? No, I had it and got rid of it. I listened to like CDs. Come on, really?
Did you really? Yeah. I did, but I mean, my agency gave me CDs and I listened to them and I did them and like repeated all of the things. But I think that probably just time. Time, yeah, time in Los Angeles. Especially that young 14, 50, you just start sounding like your surrounding. Yeah, I got rid of my Canadian accent, the same way.
When? Get out, Sean. How dear you? You just said A and I think a boat. A boat. What part of Canada? I've worked there, so I know all the provinces. Toronto.
Oh, okay. Yeah. Cool. Big city guy. Yeah, I'm a big city dude. That's kind of my cross-to-me. I'm more familiar with the Quebec region. Okay.
Is that Montreal? That's the Montreal is in Quebec, yeah. Montreal's in Quebec, yeah. Beautiful part of the world. Here's a question I know Sean's going to love. You joke that you once fan girl too hard on meeting Jack Nicholson. What is your most recent embarrassing celebrity encounter? I think I, like, frightened Draco Malfoy.
What's his name? Tom Feldman. Yeah, really? We were doing Fallon and, you know how dark it is? And those, like when you're, like, behind the curtain or whatever, it's so dark on the late shows. And I had finished and was walking out. He was going to go on after me.
And I just was like, I was like scared him. Really? Yeah. You're so fan. You fan out. I know it's wild when you run into people that you kind of, that stuck with you because of a film when you were growing up or whatever
and you finally see them. Yeah. I know. And then it's just like you say like you love them so much and then they're nice and then it just stops. Yeah. Yeah. The conversation just I just ran into Molly Ringwald like a year ago. I was like, oh my God.
I mean Nathan Felder. He was at a party and I tried to keep. I think I kept my cool. But yeah. I had the same thing with him. I said that he was like the best and I'm such a big fan. And he was like, oh my gosh, thank you. End of conversation.
Yeah. And Nathan Fielder and Larry David are, they're intense because it's like it's their brain that you are so like, you like their personality and like their brain. You know, not just like what they do. Like if they don't like me. then why would I like me? I know. You want to get in there. We're billing by the aisle.
Oh, my God, this is so revelatory. I want their approval. All right, here's another spicy hot question. Hot ones, you confess to eating weird snacks on set. What is your all-time strangest onset food combo that you now secretly stand by? I have no idea what that means. It's a weird onset. I just eat what's at crafty.
Right, exactly. My brothers used to think that, like, my breakfasts were gross. Like I would have like Campbell's chicken noodle soup and like tuna salad. I get it. Okay. Wow. Sean, hump the brakes.
How did you do? That sounds delicious. Sean just like, I did hot ones just recently myself. How'd you do, Willie? Did you get all the way through it? If I'm being honest, I was like,
I was reluctant to do it because I don't like eating. I don't like hot sauce. And so I'm like, okay, here we go. And then they go. Bateman was just on and he made it all the way through. Yeah. But I was loaded up with like Pepto and Tom's,
Oh, I threw up. You did? You did? Yeah. Wait, is it true that milk really helps that? Yes, milk helps. Really? It did help. But the third to last one, I forget it was like, I forget it was called like the bomb or something like that.
It was so ridiculous. And I was rubbing the ice cream on my lips because I thought that my lips were going to come off. That sounds gross. It sounds like a dream. No, it's like truly frightening when it hits. It's overwhelming. It was rough. Like, how am I going to handle this situation?
When did you throw up on the set there or when you got home? No. So the only thing that soothed the burning was chugging ice water. So I think what happened was I drank so much ice water that I threw up. Wow. This is the kind of torture we put ourselves through to sell our product. Yeah. But actually, it was pretty fun.
He's a great, he's a super nice guy, Sean. Yeah, he's a very good interviewer. Very good. Very good questions. By the way, the questions are really good, and they're really from out of left field. It made me laugh a couple times how out of left field. And you're struggling with your mouth is on fire. And I love how, like, dry and robotic he is, too.
Yeah. It's like, it's fucking serious business. Yes. He's a robot. He just doesn't react as much because he's used to it. Yeah, he's used to it. He's made of titanium. It's insane. He actually kind of mirrors you, what I found.
Like, he eats the same way that you do. He takes the same size bites that you do. And there's some, I guess there's comfort in that. It's almost like he's in it with you. Yeah. Did you take just... That poor guy. He said whenever he goes to restaurants, people send him chicken wings.
Oh, boy. And he obviously Sean, dream. Yeah. Send him over here. Yeah. All right. What about this?
If fame disappeared tomorrow, Jen, what is the first thing that you would go out and do? That you can't do now because of getting recognized. Oh. I don't. That doesn't really apply. I just do stuff. What about like, well, like, will you do like Disneyland?
Yeah, but I'll do Disney. I'll do it. You just rush it. And then, so then what happens? I just rush it. What happens if? like a big crowd starts to gather around you and everybody wants a picture on their iPhones.
Do you indulge? No, it never happens. And like I would just leave. I think that bringing like a big security guard and like wearing a hat and all that stuff, that attracts attention. But if for the most part, I just get people like looking at me sideways
being like she looks like that person. Yeah, you don't want to invite it. So I would just do that. You don't want to invite it. I remember hearing this is a guy's told me once this is not related. I can't believe I'm a man. making this connection.
But riding your bike in the city that don't wear a helmet because, again, this is a terrible analogy, but I can't bail them too deep. That when you wear a helmet, you say to the other drivers that you're part of the system that you're just another vehicle.
But if you don't have a helmet, that you recognize as a human. So when I ride my bike in the city, I never wear a helmet. This sounds like Thoreau again. You know who said it? Lauren Michaels, who's never been in a bike in the city in his life. Yeah, my God.
But he once said that to me. Did he deliver it like it was a good joke, or did he deliver it serious? No, he meant to do it. No, he said, wouldn't you put a helmet on? You're telling the other vehicles that you're in the game. Because I was considering starting to wear a helmet. He said, don't do it. He advised me, Lauren.
So, like, if you don't have a helmet on, then they'll be more careful around you, right? That's right. That's right, because they see that you're a human being. All right. I don't know why, but I find it. weird when Canadians are funny. Because there's so many of them that are funny. Well, there's Jim Carrey.
There's Jim, there's Martin Short. Martin Short is kind of... Of course. Once you find out somebody's Canadian, you're like, of course. And I don't know what it is. John Candy? Marty Short might be one of the levels.
John Candy's Canadian? Of course. John Candy definitely seems like he's from Chicago. Well, we know why. We were just talking about playing strange and I'm in the album bills. Canada has a deep bench. if I can to you. Deep,
of funny people. That's a hockey analogy, like a bench, like a, you know. I guess I just, like, there's, to me,
there's no trauma in Canada. It's like, you have free health care. You, the, your taxes pay for public school. Everybody's so nice. Like, what are you,
I feel like humor is formed from suffering. Maybe you're cold. We just suck it up. Before, wait, before we let her go, we've got, God damn it,
we're in the last minute. We haven't even talked about the thing. Let's talk. I want to talk, Lynn Ransy's, one of my favorite directors ever. Can you please, okay, so die my love, right?
Yes? Yeah, that's the film. It's incredible. Saw it, love it. Can you tell us anything about what I'm assuming was a magical experience with Lynn Ramsey? Yeah, I mean, it really was. It started like before we got on set, she just kind of started like talking about this world
and then writing these scenes. And like it wasn't necessarily like in chronological order, which was funky and cool. And then we got to Canada to, it was Calgary, which was in... Where if that was, it was beautiful. What's the Ottawa province? No, Alberta is. Alberta.
And... I'm here for all your Canadian questions. Yeah, thank you. You're welcome. incredible in that and so was Robert Pattinson. I can't wait to see it. The movie's so great. I can't wait to see it.
It's just beautiful too. I guess we'd just see it before, Sean. I already saw it. Really? Do you have a top movie of all time for you or top two? Oh, Sean. Well, now, I mean, one battle after another was my favorite movie I've ever seen. It's incredible.
What about, wait, you're a reality TV fan. Do you watch any of those of your husband? He doesn't get near him? He got near Vanderpump for a while, but now I lost him. But yeah, I watch Southern Trump. Charm Real Housewives of Salt Lake and Real Housewives of Beverly Hills now. What about Below Deck? Do we go Below Deck at all? You know, I can't watch Below Deck because I cannot understand the different franchises of
them. It's too confusing. I don't ever know which one is current. Is it Below Deck? Below Deck, Med, Below Deck, Australia. I don't know which one's happening now. You've got to be clear on those. You have to, there can't be confusion when you're in the below deck universe. Exactly. Do you ever watch traders? Like, what happens if I confuse? What would happen? What region I meant, I'm clearly passionate about promises. Wait, Sean, what was that? You're describing chaos.
You ever watched traitors? Traders. Oh, wait, that's the one that was just in England. Yeah. Yeah, it's so good. Where they play mafia, basically, DB, they play mafia. And they're doing that in the States now, too, right? Remember last year at New Year's how much we played mafia every night?
You were great at it. I had to run it every night because everybody else. And I couldn't even play. I had to run it every night. It wouldn't have lasted with that. You were a beacon. Do you guys ever do bowls? Boles?
What is it? Salad bowls. What's that? Everybody writes down something that's familiar to everybody. Like everybody would get it, you know, like Spider-Man, Donald Trump, like, cheese. Yeah. And then you put them, and then there's like stage one, which is you can say every, you can say a full sentence just without that word. Yeah.
And then the second, you can just say one word. And then the third is charades. Some people call it celebrity or what do they call it? Oh, it has a different name for everybody. Oh, that sounds very good. So the first round you do, yeah, you get one sentence to describe it, then you put them all back in the bowl in the second round. And it's always the same.
So then you started getting these inside jokes with, you know, it's just like the same. It's very funny. Shawnee, you used to have great game nights. What happened? What's going on? Too much, too much. I love game nights. I see, a lot of people do.
Too much to host. Let's get the game to organize. Let's get on down to Jamie and Nico's house and just fire up a big fat game night. Oh, yeah. I'll fly in. You know, it's game nights always happen where people are like into it and then you start it and then people kind of fall out because they get bored and then it's kind of...
Yeah, that's the bummer. I'm going to start doing Monjeon with my girls on Thursday. I love Mahjong. I don't know how to play yet. We're going to learn. It's just a matching game. Is that the one with the tiles? Yeah, you just match the tiles.
That's it. Oh. Huh. That's it. Those are the rules. Really? Yeah. Yeah. That's all too much. Yeah.
All right. Jennifer. Jen. J.B. Thank you. Sean. Will. Next time you're out here.
Will shirt. Doing your things. Thank you. Let us know. And we'll play some Mahjong and some bowls. We'll do a game night at Shons. Yeah. We'll do some bowls.
Sean's going to. Sean's going to do some pictures. Sean, I'll help you organize and I'll come early and we can set up appetizers and stuff. Yeah, right. Crutiton. Bullshit? Then I can like be. They're already out.
The appetizers are already out. Pop darts just in a row. Oh, Sean. Jen, thank you very, very much for doing that. Thank you. So nice to finally meet you. Jennifer Lawrence. This is lovely.
Thank you for having me. All right, have a great rest of the day. Yeah. And have a great holiday. All right. Thank you. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, Jail. Bye.
That's Jennifer Lawrence. That's what was supposed to be on the big stage at the Hollywood Bowl. I know. She got rained out. We got it. We got it. And yet we still, and then we had her, and then we, and then we just had her on here, which was amazing, which was great.
I know. And when I, when I found out that that was, so it was like after it got canceled, I was like, oh, it was Jennifer Lawrence. I was so excited. And then, and here she is. Now, did you guys, you guys did not know it was her. Not until after. No idea.
No. No. No idea. And I knew, I knew it was going to be Jeremy Allen White a week beforehand. You did. Oh, right. Yeah. Yeah.
Because, right. Yeah. Because his agent mentioned it at something I was at. Oh, right. Right. But he, but, but, but, but, not his fault. Yeah, of course. But, yeah, that would have been, that would have been a, I can't believe it took us so long to have her on.
I know. She's one of those like, oh. On the peak, I know. She's sort of like. She was on my list, too. Yeah. I mean, she's fantastic. She has a lot of success quickly, but she handles it well.
Very well. She's had so many great things. She's been so good and so many things. She's been in a movie every year for the last 20 years. I was looking on her thing. Is that a single year? Is that right, eh? Is that right, eh?
Yeah. And then, so die my love is out now. And then the Hunger Games, next Hunger Games thing, I think is coming out middle of next year. How about that? That's... You know it. Go ahead, Sean. You know what? Die My Love's coming out.
Thank God, I mean, it's a good title. Thank God it was entitled. Bye, my love! That's exactly what I was going to do. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.